a small town made famous by classic 80s
films becomes the site of another mass
shooting it's a sick vicious cycle that
keeps happening over and over and we're
doing nothing about it
adele on how many more kids she wants
and why she stands by her decision to
delay her vegas residency my nerves
means i want to go and do a great show
when i don't feel like that then i'm
done
i won't do it anymore
stranger things fan favorites react to
the dramatic season four finale i'm
always
looking to go as far as i can and this
was an opportunity to do that
let's hope they hear this
and the metallica song getting the kate
bush treatment
[Music]
18's the dow mode starts right now
we begin with anguish in illinois after
the deadly fourth of july parade
shooting now at least seven people were
killed and more than two dozen injured
when a gunman opened fire from a roof
near the parade route in highland park a
northern suburb of chicago
members of our community who came out to
celebrate together
and instead faced this terror
officials say a person of interest was
arrested nearly nine hours after the
rampage now in the aftermath president
biden shared this message about
america's democracy while speaking at
the white house i signed a law
the first real gun safety law in 30
years
and things
will get better still but not without
more hard work together
you all heard what happened
we all heard what happened today
but each day we're reminded
there's nothing guaranteed about our
democracy
nothing guaranteed about our way of life
we have to fight for it
defend it
and earn it
by voting the tragedy is sparking more
pleas for change including this call to
action from la galaxy star sasha
cleshton it's a sick vicious cycle that
keeps happening over and over and we're
doing nothing about it and it makes me
sick
i don't know congress senators if anyone
sees this do do something
and the shooting is sending shock waves
across hollywood rachel brosnahan a
highland park native is expressing her
heartbreak on twitter writing i grew up
in highland park and this parade is a
highlight of the year for so many
families i'm sick to my stomach every
time news like this comes out but i
don't wish the pit in your stomach as
you call your family and friends to make
sure everyone is okay on anyone no words
rachel ended her message with a simple
sentiment which she repeats multiple
times enough is enough like rachel actor
gary sinise calls the city his hometown
we originally were up in highland park
which is where i grew up and went to
high school it's about 25 miles north of
chicago
and this is a town you probably
recognized because it served as the
backdrop for several iconic movies
including ferris bueller's day off home
alone and also risky business meanwhile
harry styles canceled his show in
copenhagen on sunday after another
deadly shooting near his venue officials
say three people were killed and three
others injured when a gunman opened fire
inside a shopping mall in denmark's
capital city harry wrote on twitter i'm
heartbroken adore the city i'm
devastated for the victims their
families and everyone hurting
meanwhile over in the uk adele wrapped
up her first two concerts in five years
in london's hyde park it was also her
first performance since postponing her
las vegas residency in a new interview
with bbc radio's desert island discs
adele says she was devastated she had to
cancel those shows but it was the right
move i definitely felt everyone's
disappointment
and i was devastated
and i was frightened
about you know letting them down i'm so
sorry but um
[Music]
my show ain't ready and i thought i
could pull it together and make it work
and i couldn't and i stand by that
decision
you'll remember in january adele
tearfully pulled out of the weekends
with adele shows just days before she
was due to hit the stage at the coliseum
at caesar's palace the singer says the
backlash was brutal it was horrible and
it was it was the the reaction was
brutal
brutal
i was a shell of a person for a couple
of months how did you get through that
i just had to wait it out had to wait
out and um
and just grieve it i guess just grieve
the shows and
you know get over the guilt um
yeah but it was brutal
thankfully adele told the crowd at the
first of two hyde park shows that she
will announce new dates for the las
vegas shows quote very very soon but can
we talk about her london concerts
because i was there and it was clear
adele missed performing for her fans i
mean she was overcome with emotion
throughout the performance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
among adele's famous fans in the crowd
aside from denny james corden natalie
portman and idris alba and get this
adele's boyfriend rich paul was also
spotted watching the concert with her
ex-husband simon kaneki alongside
cameron diaz and husband benji madden
can we talk about the happy blended
family i mean totally and that great
co-parenting relationship with her ex is
something adele actually told bbc radios
all because of her son angelo it was
never really tricky because
we're such good friends and um over my
dead body is my kid having like a messy
divorce in his life there are no issues
as for whether adele is ready to expand
her family i definitely would like a
couple more kids
it'd be wonderful if we can if not i've
got angelo like you know
i just want to be happy
another star who showed up for adele tom
cruise he celebrated his 60th birthday
in the uk reportedly singing and dancing
backstage and on sunday which was his
actual birthday tom pulled up to the
british grand prix to cheer on his
friend formula one race driver lewis
hamilton and tom has every reason to
celebrate after the success of top gun
maverick the film has made 1.1 billion
dollars with worldwide billing with a b
i'm very proud of what we all
accomplished
each one of them are extraordinary tom's
co-star miles teller is also riding high
from the film's huge milestone so much
so that his grandmother has launched a
campaign for him to be the next james
bond nana leona flowers tweeted i think
my grandson has proven that he has
everything they're looking for talent
looks strength worldwide appeal and oh
so cool he could be that guy wouldn't he
be great but critics point out he's not
british banana says his acting would
make you think he was and he and we know
he could even bring his music skills to
the table
come on baby you're driving me crazy
as for top gun maverick after flying
high for six weeks minions the rise of
grooves snagged the number one spot at
the box office raking in 218 million
dollars worldwide in its debut weekend
that makes it the biggest july 4th
opening ever
this is the biggest day of my life
this kid just stole something from the
world's villains in the world
time to strike now i will be a
villain
now to rihanna nearly two months since
becoming a mom she's making her first
public appearance in a place you'd never
expect the barber shop check out this
instagram video from london reread
chillin in the shop with the rest of the
customers while her man asap rocky gets
a fresh cut right there the woman who
posted the video captioned it if you see
this post my soul has been snatched lol
girl all of us are you in that moment
back in may rihanna and asap welcome to
baby boy into the world with a source
telling e.t they are over the moon she's
been looking forward to motherhood for a
long time and if that wasn't enough to
celebrate forbes has named rihanna
america's youngest self-made billionaire
at 31 years old she has a net worth of
1.4 billion dollars you know some folks
thought kylie jenner was the queen but
forbes recalled her billionaire title
when they discovered the numbers had
been miscalculated and she hadn't earned
quite that much yet kim kardashian was
actually the previous title holder with
1.8 billion but she's 10 years older
than rihanna kim's clearly enjoying all
that dough she and north are living it
up at paris fashion week north is even
rocking her dad's vintage pastel jacket
kim's man pete davidson is making
headlines too because of someone he
might have dated singer olivia o'brien
she seemed caught off guard when she was
asked about their previous connection on
the barstool sports podcast bffs with
david portnoy
your eyes just popped yeah the uh
pete
i didn't think that anyone knew about
that you're the first people that ever
asked me about that and i really thought
that no one knew about that here's where
it gets messy now olivia claims pete
broke up with her in a not so nice way
after rumors began to circulate that he
was dating bridgeton's phoebe denver who
a lot of fans thought looked similar to
her he
texted me i was like i'm seeing someone
else so like i can't he and it's the
same
but i didn't have red hair at the time
since the story broke a few days ago
pete's rep have come out and said he
never dated olivia and the two were just
friends who hung out a few times she
seems to agree by the way in a since
deleted ig story posted friday she says
she never claimed to have dated anyone
and she asked fans to stop starting
weird drama over me texting someone two
years ago
meanwhile kim's sister courtney is
sticking by husband travis barker's side
after his health scare last week and it
appears he's on the mend here he is
yesterday out of the hospital with his
family on a low-key joy ride to the
beach in his orange vintage truck
courtney is there in the passenger seat
with her kiddos penelope and rayne in
the back we're just you know living our
best lives and
yeah
the famed drummer is shedding more light
on what caused his life-threatening case
of pancreatitis on saturday he wrote
that after an endoscopy he had a small
polyp removed in a sensitive area and
during the procedure a critical
pancreatic drainage tube was damaged
intense treatment followed which led to
his recovery and look mom-in-law chris
sent her well wishes with this beautiful
bouquet courtney also called the
experience scary and emotional while
calling out the paparazzi for reaching a
new level of low selling weeks old
photos making it seem like she was out
and about while travis was still
hospitalized she says she never left his
side an et source told us last week that
courtney was the one to rush him to the
hospital before he was transferred
elsewhere via ambulance
while those newlyweds seem closer than
ever exes amber heard and johnny depp
are still feuding their highly
publicized defamation trial wrapped up
almost five weeks ago but now heard
wants the jury's verdict thrown out in
new documents obtained by e.t she's
claiming that one the evidence didn't
support the outcome of the case and two
one of the jurors was not properly
vetted saying public records show that
person is 25 years older than what's
noted in court documents last month the
judge ordered amber to pay debt more
than 10 million dollars that judgment
came after a jury found that she defamed
him in a 2018 washington post op-ed in
it she claimed that she was the victim
of domestic abuse
i could just hear him say that he was
going to kill me
and
i thought this is how i die
he's gonna kill me now it's insane
to
hear
heinous
um
accusations
of
violence sexual violence
that she's attributed to me
in the new motions filed by heard she
argues that depp's team did not prove
that she acted with malice when she
wrote the article and that a potential
error should be grounds for a new trial
so damages could be addressed again the
problem is we're dealing with a a level
celebrity and 10 million dollars is not
too far-fetched for the amount of money
that he lost by virtue of her statements
so with respect to the juror's id not
having been verified it's very unlikely
that that's going to result in
something that is a potentially a
mistrial or the verdict is set aside
very unlikely
meanwhile lindsay lohan is live in her
fairy tale e.t can confirm that the mean
girl star is a married woman that is so
fetch
gretchen stop trying to make fetch
happen
and here's her new husband dubai based
financier bader shamas on friday lindsay
posted this photo of herself calling
herself the luckiest woman in the world
every woman should feel like this every
day the two have been engaged since
november and have been together since at
least february of 2020 a year before
that lindsay told us what she was
looking for in a partner someone who's
hates the spotlight
[Laughter]
no seriously someone who doesn't have
instagram like a smart
businessman
you know she also told us she wants a
family and it sounds like she hit her
mark if bader does have an instagram
he's at least keeping it locked down
this account that appears to be his is
private and only has about 600 followers
another couple in wedded bliss blake
shelton and gwen stefani
when did you know gwen was the one for
you
uh it didn't take long it ended up being
the greatest moment of my life blake
celebrated their first wedding
anniversary yesterday by sharing this
photo with fans and thanking gwen for
saying yes and you can bet gwen was in
the comments calling blake her dream man
um blake saved my life everybody knows
that
but yeah can we also give blake some
extra husband points for the photoshop
job on his profile pic i mean nicely
done blake all right brian austin green
is getting all the points too from the
mother of his fifth child girlfriend
sharna burgess i'm excited for
this time in life
and i'm excited for what it is we're
doing and uh and i'm excited that she's
in my life
and uh i
i i think she's amazing my kids love her
it's like it's it's it's a win-win right
now their first baby together zane is
officially a week old today and the
dancing with the stars pro let fans know
that she was able to take this photo
because brian gave her the night off
from feedings that way she could get a
full night of sleep making her grateful
beyond words for everything he does he
is an amazing dad i can tell you that
he's one of the best i've ever known or
witnessed
this is sharna's first child and she
says it's beautifully overwhelming to
process adding i know i'll never be the
same again ever but she did get some
practice with her step kids
she just instinctually
sort of knows how to
not be a step not be a step parent in
that way but like really
just bond with them and love them and
they feel really safe with her and it
and it's it's an amazing connection that
they have i love spending time with the
boys i love having them in my life that
makes me smile
someone who's single and ready to mingle
lori harvey who was in new orleans
chowing down on some local eats while in
town for the essence festival of culture
you can see her here on a panel in the
same outfit meantime rex michael b
jordan was way across the country at a
star-studded independence day party in
malibu the guest list included kevin
hart jamie foxx and leo dicaprio nbj and
lori split last month after about a year
together a source told et at the time
they were both heartbroken and upset and
at different stages in their lives
many people feeling heartbroken after
watching the emotional season four
finale of stranger things no spoilers
we're not going to spoil it
don't worry daddy but i had the chance
to talk with some of the cast on how the
show's breaking records and at one point
even breaking netflix
and you guys crashed netflix how
embarrassing
i was awake when it happened i saw it
come through my twitch i was like this
is amazing did you see the memes of
people posting you as fekna drinking
coffee through a straw like me just
waiting for netflix to pop back up i
didn't see that last night no that's
amazing viewers streamed over 300
million hours of stranger things last
week fun fact this kiss between david
harbor and winona ryder was improvised
oh and we have more behind
behind-the-scenes secrets straight from
eddie and beckmann themselves you
have already lost
the way my mouth opens at the end they
were like your mouth opened so wide we
thought that like it had been like cgs
and i was like that's hilarious like you
were possessed i was like well you know
it was like two o'clock in the morning
[Music]
so how much of that is you playing
master of puppets that is an awesome
moment
it's pretty much all of me i was lucky
that i've kind of played guitar since i
was quite young who wouldn't want to
kind of be a rock star for an afternoon
we know that it will be a stranger thing
spin-off as for season 5 creators the
duffer brothers say it's just going to
be going 100 miles an hour from the
beginning we're definitely going to be
seeing you again in season 5 right
i couldn't possibly say you'll have to
hold your breath
[Music]
thanks once again to stranger things
metallica's master of puppets is
trending big time on monday the song
landed at number 12 on spotify's top 50
songs in the u.s and 26 on the
platform's global top 50. the base the
band's bassist robert trujillo revealing
on instagram his son actually provided
some of the additional guitar tracks
heard during episode nine
[Music]
meanwhile the now iconic anthem from
kate bush running up that hill is number
two on spotify's us list and number
three globally gotta love stranger
things right killer story killer
throwback music that really gets stuck
in my head like come on kate bush all
right how's this for a throwback after
the break we're going behind the scenes
of men in black released 25 years ago
today
what is it about you that makes you so
likable i'm just really attractive you
know what the difference is between you
and me
[Music]
i make this look good
[Applause]
and we wouldn't want it any other way
drake teams up with the backstreet boys
the download returns
[Music]
you try your best
love heart i'm single i obviously don't
know how to make it work yeah but he's
not single anymore a source tells e.t
that chris rock and lake bell are dating
and have been for a couple of months
adding chris is hyper focused on his
tour so it seems he really likes her
since he's making seeing her a priority
now the two were open about their
romance over the weekend just spotted
out together on multiple occasions
including this dinner date at celebrity
hot spot giorgio baldi and santa monica
now they look like the perfect pair lake
in all black chris and all white with
brown oxford shoes and an eyewitness
tells e.t they were spotted holding
hands
it's good to see chris moving on from
that
oscar slap our source says he's in a
really good headspace meanwhile the will
smith classic men in black is turning
25. you remember the little red button
yeah push the little red button
and you may want to put on a seat belt
[Music]
suited booted and kicking alien butt
you know you're much too tense you're a
young man you need to relax learn to
take some joy in your work you have
another big summer blockbuster you know
well you know you're picked by the team
and this you tommy lee jones and steven
spielberg you can't really lose with
that kind of team what is it about you
that makes you so likable i'm just
really attractive
there's a very action-packed movie this
is like the ultimate police force
the idea is that we have to keep all
this alien traffic through our little
backwater border town of a planet
secret all the men in black are kind of
old then it's time to recruit new
members and i'm the first new member
that tommy lee recruits
what's so funny edwards i got no clue
why we're here this was will's third big
blockbuster bad boys and independence
day the year before had already made him
a mega star but this time he got to make
some music too the soundtrack won him a
grammy award for the best rap solo
performance
[Music]
it's really exciting you know especially
when you get that combination of the
music and the film that go together and
it's kind of a cool concept everybody
likes the sunglasses and the black suits
and that whole secret of things but it
was no secret that the magic couldn't
have happened without state of the art
special effects rick's stuff is is not
only really imaginative but it's really
witty also i mean there's spin on all of
it and both of those things are
absolutely essential that's what's fun
about this you know we're doing you know
we've got men in suits we've got little
mechanical guys we have big mechanical
guys
all kinds of makeups it's
pretty much everything i've done through
my career all packed into one movie i
knew it would be a blast to work with
him and it took about
took a couple of months to develop the
makeup with him and develop this
way this character looks
ah
is that letter
would you want to do another men in
black
you never say no he and will both said
yes to sequels men in black 2 and 3 were
both big hits the franchise has made
nearly two billion dollars worldwide
over the years
you know you get a much better reaction
if you're a little more polite fasten
your seatbelt please whoa that was good
[Music]
[Music]
well it looks like the backstreet boys
have a new honorary member during the
toronto stop of their dna world tour
they were joined by an epic surprise
guest
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yup that's toronto native drake rallying
fans on stage he told the nearly sold
out crowd he's been a fan of bsb since
he was just 13 years old drizzy later
shared a clip of the moment on instagram
writing when she says she's over men in
this generation and asks why i live
alone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i never knew i needed this until now now
you got it oh man
i got that for you i'm more of an
in-sync guy but i love that drake's a
super bsb
do it for us today all right tune in
tomorrow for another episode of et's the
download bye everyone
[Music]
you